in eastern Spain in the city of valves
there's a legendary onion
locals will tell you that at the end of
the 19th century a farmer named chant of
anages carried out an experiment
he planted a crop of onions
but instead of letting them grow as
usual he increased the depth of the soil
above them as they grew
[Music]
this caused the stems to lengthen and
remain white not as sharp as a spring
onion and not as subtle as a leak these
onions called calcs are mild sweet and
most importantly exceptionally delicious
[Music]
not long after the onions creation local
families began hosting calcite eating
parties and in 1982 the onion was
granted its own Festival the grand Festa
de la calcitata is
momento the cow sounds are cooked over
hot coals and Grapevine clippings giving
them a rich Smoky flavor
the burnt outer layer is removed and the
inner part is dipped in a tomato and
garlic salbachata sauce
[Music]
thank you
local farmers participate in a
competition for the best calcite
this is Del Massey he is a seasoned cow
sock grower and an esteemed competition
judge is
[Music]
foreign
while the onions are the main event
there's plenty more to do including a
grand parade
a competition for the best sauce
and a selection of meats and sausages to
try
so no one gets thirsty local wine is
readily available served from a
traditional Quran
but when it comes to eating calcs some
Festival goers have a little more
experience than others
this year Atria a 221 kelsots that's
more than 3 kilos in just 45 minutes
[Music]
analysis
respect
foreign
[Music]